But let me tell you why I like your idea
behind your podcast, right?
Because you stepped away from the
political side and you said, that's
here. But here I actually just want to
have regular talks, a regular
conversation. When did you make the
choice? Right. Because in stand up, you
have comedians that make the choice to
take the turn and go political and
start to address real issues, real
problems. When was it that you made a
decision to say, you know what, man?
Like and being funny is great, but I'm
going to I'm going to shift the
narrative and start to address my funny
with a clever approach to talking about
the problems that I see in the country.
Right.
Well, again, like the other thing, it's
an evolution that I almost couldn't
stop from happening because my father
was in news. My father was a radio
newsman in the day when every news
station in the radio had news at the
top of the hour. So that's what he did
for a living. So my parents were
interested in the news.
I heard about it at home.
We weren't a lot like a lot of families
where they don't they didn't pay
attention. They don't know and give a
shit. They don't give a shit.
Politics just wasn't what was talked
about. So it was always in my ear.
And my father was a good living room
comedian, which is something a lot of
comedians will tell you that it kind of
gestates over one generation that the
the parent one or maybe both parents.
My mother was witty to show you that in
the home again the the background of
what you have at home and and so like
the idea that I would go into comedy
with a bent toward not just news but
stuff that was in the culture,
something that was meaty and important
and something you could talk about and
chew on that has some intellectual
nutrition to it as opposed to just
trivia, which you can that can be
genius comedy too, but it's just not my
style. That was always, I feel like
inevitable given what was in my home.
Now, the downside of it for me is that
people see me especially as a standup,
as like this political comedian.
And that's not really when you see me
do standup, you don't really have to
know a hell of a lot about politics.
Of course I'm going to make it.
That's what my show is.
Also, I'm doing this for the people who
don't follow it that closely, who want
someone to interpret for them and, you
know, give an opinion of it and make it
funny and make it palatable.
Make little, little sugar to help the
medicine go down.
So, you know, when you come to see me
do standup. Yes. You don't have to be
up on the news. And I'm not just
political. I talk about my personal
life and everything in my standup.
That's that's what we love to do.
Supposed to do. I mean, that's what
makes us that's what makes us not only
relatable, but that's what gives us the
legs, right? You're able to continue
year after year after year because
you're talking about your growth, your
trajectory.
But my real my main job I was kidding
with you before my real job, the one
I'm going to get back to today as soon
as I leave here and I work on all week
is real Time on HBO that, you know,
it's a once a week show on a premier
cable network. I have to make that show
as good as I can.
And once a week for one hour, I have
one hour to try to tell people what
happened that week that I think is
important and give them my slant on it
and make it so entertaining they can't
turn that dial.
So that's my main thing.
And then stand up is just my is like my
mistress. It's way more fun because I'm
not married to her.
Who?